the view expressed this this total
disconnect with ordinary voters with
what's actually happening in the country
I know shocking right when uh the the
fake Republican on The View mentioned
the Congressional baseball shooting to
make a point defending Democrats of
course because that's all she ever does
and uh the Democrats on The View
appeared not to even know what she was
talking about
what is on the rise is political
violence and I want to say unequivocally
political violence Left Right Center is
wrong to those of my party who are not
calling this out directly shame on you
this is an 82 year old man he's being
charged with elderly abuse for what he
did and really quickly I was working for
the freedom caucus when the 2017
Congressional baseball shooting today my
bosses were actually targeted at the
time Cruz was part of the freedom Corps
no it's actually just house members but
um Steve scalise was nearly killed yes
um in that shooting the difference is
every Democrat roundly condemned it and
they rooted for his recovery
okay so that's not true there were very
prominent Democrats who didn't roundly
condemnity to root for his recovery one
of them is the Wisconsin Democrats
Senate candidate right now Mandela
Barnes who made fun of Steve scalise for
getting shot and tweeted out a picture
of Steve scalise on a little scooter you
know as he was recovering and it said
taking one for the team I question how
people vote against self-interest but
this is next level he literally almost
died on this hill you know hahaha Steve
scalise almost got shot he should
abandon the Second Amendment so Alyssa
Farah's point is an extremely dumb one
but not as dumb as her colleagues who
when she says you know I was I was
working in the freedom caucus during the
Congressional baseball shooting and Joy
Behar goes what's that
and it's unclear from the clip was Joy
Bay Sunny hoston thinks that Joy Behar
was asking what does the Freedom caucus
but it's unclear from the clip it might
be that Joy Behar was asking what was
the Congressional baseball shooting I'm
not surprised I think if you pulled 100
Democrats right now on the street you
said hey what do you think of the
Congressional baseball shooting probably
97 of them would not know what it is
because it was downplayed by the media
because it involved a leftist trying to
murder conservatives but even if she
asks what's the freedom caucus what do
you mean what's the freedom caucus
that's the main Republican Outlet in the
House of Representatives
what do you mean you don't know what
that is and then the the co-host who's
supposed to know anything about American
politics says that's the thing Ted Cruz
was in and the poor fake Republican has
to correct her and say no actually
it's just in the house and Ted Cruz is
in the Senate so there's okay hosts of a
major public affairs show there's
there are there are two houses in the
Congress there's the House of
Representatives and the Senate and then
there's there are three branches of
government you know there's a
legislature and the Jews and they just
they just don't know anything they don't
know anything and they can get away with
not knowing anything because the libs
have all of the Power so it doesn't
really matter and because they've
destroyed American Education the people
don't really call them on it but they
they can't get away with it forever okay
people recognize eventually when things
are going wrong when something's wrong
in their government with the people
running the show have no idea what the
hell they're doing and that's happening
right now even people who don't study
political philosophy and you don't have
very fancy degrees and haven't worked on
Capitol Hill they can look around and
say crime is going up the economy is in
the gutter they're trying to chop off my
kids genitals the border is completely
unsecure millions of foreigners are
flooding in we're on the brink of World
War III whoever is running the show I
don't want to hear any of your stupid
excuses about it's Putin's fault it's
the Republican it's the misinformation
whatever it is you've got the buck stops
with you you guys have done a terrible
job and we're going to vote you out
Harvard is on the ropes Harvard and UNC
there they've been dragged before The
Supreme Court
because a group has sued them for their
racial discrimination in admission
practices
and this is going all the way up to the
highest court in the land and they're
saying look Harvard you discriminate
against Asians you discriminate against
white people you give an unfair
advantage to black students you have an
unfair advantage to Hispanic students
and this is wrong and it certainly
should be it seems like it should be
unconstitutional seems like it is
unconstitutional but we've tolerated
this for many decades in the country and
it's just wrong it's wrong that people
are discriminated against on their race
it's wrong that a white kid or an Asian
kid or some you know some Vietnamese
immigrant who works really hard and
doesn't come from a lot of money and
doesn't come from a lot of privilege and
just works really really hard is
disadvantaged because his facial
features look a certain way and his skin
is a certain color that's wrong to do
and we all know it and you got to stop
it and the Supreme Court seems poised to
to accept that argument because it's
obviously true so Harvard is fighting
back
they're fighting but they have no
argument I played it yesterday where the
lawyer for UNC was asked by Clarence
Thomas a simple question
what is the educational benefit of
diversity
and he couldn't answer that question
he could he said well the the diversity
is good because everyone says it's good
there's a consensus that it's really
good and Clarence Thomas says uh okay
but you're not
you you're you're telling me what's
popular but you're not you're telling me
what's fashionable in certain liberal
circles you're not telling me what
you're not answering the question what
is the educational benefit the guy
couldn't give an educational benefit and
so now Harvard's trying to run away from
this and Harvard's Harvard is
simultaneously trying to argue that they
they discriminate on the basis of race
and they need to protect their right to
discriminate on the basis of race but
they also don't discriminate on the
basis of race so Harvard tweets out a
fact check it's so amazing it's so
pathetic that Harvard which once was a
prestigious academic institution is now
resorting to the same stupid political
tactics of online leftist commentators
you know fact check whenever they do the
fact check
all that means is it's a leftist opinion
column that is presented with the facade
of scientific certainty and objective
truth but it's not it's just an opinion
over a contentious political issue so
say fact check
Harvard has engaged in race neutral
strategies to achieve the educational
benefits of diversity for decades
hashtags code is hashtag defend
diversity
so I just want to take that on for a
second because that is a meaningless
sentence
what does that mean
by diversity Harvard means
uh
deciding which races should be more
represented and which races should be
less represented in the class that's
what they mean they're talking about
race when they talk about diversity
that's what the whole case is about
and Harvard's supposed right to
determine which Races they want more of
and which Races they want less of
but then they're saying they have race
neutral strategies
to determine which Races they want more
of and which Races they want less it's
not possible that is a semantically
impossible sentence it me it it is
simultaneously arguing for things that
are in direct conflict with one another
but then it gets even funnier because I
clicked on the stupid fact check leftist
opinion column from from Harvard and you
go in there and it says you know blah
blah blah we totally we we we're totally
constitutional we're following Supreme
Court president they say Harvard's
consideration of race neutral
Alternatives follows the law race
neutral
for several decades Harvard is engaged
in race neutral strategies to achieve
the educational benefits of diversity
which they never list by the way they
never can explain what the educational
benefits are because there aren't any
including several suggested by the
expert and the people in the in the
group bringing the case
Harvard eliminated and then reinstated
its early action program when it found
the elimination of early action was
hindering efforts to achieve racial
diversity
but is that that's not race neutral
that's obviously taking race into
consideration
uh if and then here's the key if Harvard
stopped taking race into consideration
as one factor in its admissions process
and adopted the race neutral
Alternatives that that the organization
bringing the lawsuit suggests the result
would be a class that fails to achieve
the diversity and Excellence at Harvard
seeks so there you have it it's
misrepresented in the Tweet Harvard is
saying we of course we have race neutral
policies but then when you click the
link they're saying we tried race
neutral policies and we don't like them
because we want we want racist policies
if the word racist means anything it
means this it means what Harvard is
doing
we're going to Advantage certain races
and we're going to disadvantage other
races on the basis of their race
they say we don't want that because then
we won't get the racial diversity and
Excellence that we seek
but which is it which do you want
there those are separate categories
diversity and Excellence they're
separate
Harvard is trying to argue that they're
the same if they're the same you would
use the same word if they were the same
you wouldn't need to list two different
categories
they're obviously distinct categories
if diversity were synonymous with
Excellence then Harvard wouldn't need to
worry about diversity because if they
just prioritized Excellence you would
get the exact racial makeup that Harvard
wants for whatever reason
that's not what's happening
that's why they have to disadvantage the
Asian students and the white students
that's why they have to effectively
give them a handicap on their SAT scores
and give other races a boost on their
SAT scores to achieve the racial social
engineering that Harvard wants but they
can't they can't make the argument
because they know that it's racist
so they can so they have to
simultaneously it's just the same thing
that the libs do on on virtually every
issue they say this thing that you
object to is not happening and it's
really good that it is
that's what it's about
not very convincing I don't think it's
going to convince the Supreme Court you
know the rest of the show is continuing
now you do not want to miss it this is
work Wednesday uh my producer Ben Davies
has lined up and extremely woke PSA
that's really all he's told me about it
from Forbes you don't want to miss it if
you're not a member click the link in
the description and join us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]